what's up I'm Nate bargatze from Netflix
the Tennessee kid from my own special
that's where I'm from
so go watch it and I'm here to answer
the Internet
all right would you rather be a clown or
a magician this is a good question Mike
so my dad did both and you know he's a
mix of they're both good honest
professions and I think you want to get
me you want to be a magician
a clown doesn't get the respect you
would think and so that's what is the
fiercest animal you think you could take
in a fight
pretty wild fiercest animal like a crate
like I don't know you know I don't know
and like an anteater
maybe is that a fierce animal I bet
they're more dangerous than you think
just like every animal and it's gross
because the nose and stuff but I think
you could really control their head with
the nose so I could it'd be pretty easy
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens who would it be
people pick one person it was like a fun
you know kind of fun you you know you
guys talk about Henry Winkler is he is
here he would be a good person to like
he's that you're like that's like yeah
that's like us man we're like fun you
know he used to be real cool he could
show videos of being like here's what
the evolution of what we do become to
him down the pons who would win in a
fight in their prime Michael Keaton or
Jon Jon Bon Jovi in their prime Michael
Keaton was Batman
right I'm Michael Keaton or the comedian
sustainer what if I just know him from
stand-up you tell me the stand-up
comedian Michael yeah he just stated for
like six months I'm like oh yeah I
remember that guy
so that would be when he's in his prime
when he was in a stand-up circus Jon Bon
Jovi currently in his prime both are
alive still and I'd like to get answers
off the boat
in there I mean I would imagine Michael
Keaton because he I think he's just got
like some darkness to him and Jon Bon
Jovi you know I've never seen him
telling if he's a big dude but I feel
like sometimes those guys like you meet
him
our sielmann your you know it's a very
small it's like a lady like you know and
then Michael Keaton was Batman he has to
be a decent size for that would you
rather throw up every time someone says
McDonald's or wear a fedora for the rest
of your life and if anybody asked about
it you have to sincerely say I just like
the way it looks I would rather wear the
fedora
I would be throw up every time someone
says McDonald's I don't want to be
around I'm around McDonald's a lot like
and people that talk about McDonald's
regularly so McDonald's is very much in
my life it would be too much throwing up
and a fedora I think I could get used to
be and I just like the way it looks and
like out and that's all I have to say
about it you know I like the way it
looks and then everybody I would say
it's so much to every would just know he
likes the way it looks you're stuck on a
deserted island for a year but you can
bring one person with you who do you
pick so do my wife white right this just
to see you know take the wife out of it
because that's not a fun answer this is
something that could happen in real life
so who would who is gonna be a fun Tom
Hanks I think I was bringing cuz Tom
Hanks
he was on even even though it is a movie
I would think because he studies movies
and he probably for that role so he's a
fun guy the great stories but then also
probably like I remember like he would
know some situations because he he
worked on them in a movie about a
deserted island if you're stuck in a
food and had to eat your way out of it
what would it be
so you'd be starting in the middle that
could you know sometimes I the middle is
not my my least favorite part of food I
like the condiments and the outside of
things so you know like I think Big Mac
you'd be right by the pickle they have
really good pickles there pickles are
greener than most I have a real-deal
pickle like I don't like some dill
pickles are like whiter and I like the
green ones and Wendy's went they change
their pickles is it fury eight like they
just do it like it's the same thing you
know it's like my mom trying to make me
like you don't even taste it and you're
like I do I burrito cuz you're just in
it you might as well be in it chilli
we're dude we talked about earlier a
chilli cheese burrito at Taco Bell which
they don't do anymore
so they'd have to bring it back to put
me back in it but I was a big fan I
think it'd be fun to fun to get out of
this is something I'd love to be a part
of one day
would you rather date a girl who laughs
at everything or nothing you know
it's like it's like the Seinfeld episode
the girl that doesn't laugh it nothing I
I mean I think you gonna have to go
everything just because I think nothing
would get super old and you do like I
know the feeling of no one laughing at
something you say fulfilling it all day
here you can it's I think everything is
like you can at least you know it would
definitely get super old though man it
would get so old like I think you were
obviously you want everything I could be
switching and just even in my business a
world of laughs I think I'm actually
changing going nothing because I think
it would I think it'd be too much and
nothing I could just deal with like you
know she's not fun like I did
I like this fedora it's I like the way
it looks my girlfriend is not fun I
would get used to saying those two
things and that's how I'd interim I like
the way it looks she doesn't laugh at
anything let's have a good time would
you rather have a dog's personality in a
cat body or a cat's personality in a
dog's body y'all do a lot of this kind
of stuff don't you yeah the ideal would
rather have this and of this or that in
a disk of that
dog's personality a cat body or cats
purr silly and in a dog I mean I don't
mind a cat's personality I think I would
I think I have it and you know it's like
a little like you just don't trust
everything you know just like I don't
know about this guy like it's a lot of
it it's like a lot of that and I would
rather have either mean a cat's
personality and dogs funny dogs bodies
like you know he'd be a gigantic dude
you're a big dog
no one's will talk about your
personality you know they're not gonna
say anything to your face about it
so I'll do cat person alien dogs when
you've been put in charge of running
heck oh hell to the oh heck yeah that's
yeah I would love it you are making that
6 is sensitive to me you're like you
think you can handle did you do one more
maybe
even put in charge of running HEC the
afterlife for people not evil enough for
for hell what's the first torture you
design so they're getting a torturer but
they're not simply so it's got to be it
can't be a crazy torture it has to be
something easy like an annoying like
just you know I'd give them a Mako marry
someone that laughs at nothing and they
have to live with that thank you dude
thanks buddy
absolutely
you